foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
10 best and deadliest Eldritch monsters
from movies these monsters are Lovecraft
in team or at the very least being
Sinister creatures invoking a sense of
cosmic horror of course there are more
of them out there and we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments down
below as well as your own entries so
let's get to it at number 10 we have
motor motor also known as the creature
is the main antagonist of the horror
movie the ritual she is an obscure yoden
a race of ancient giant like Gods from
NOS mythology Mora inhabits a forest in
Northern Sweden and is venerated by an
ancient group of cultures as described
in the story Moda is believed to be The
Offspring of the North's god Loki she
appears as an enormous elk like monster
with bright yellow eyes a skeletal head
adorned with antlers and a pair of
human-like hands on her hand Moda prays
on Travelers who enter her forest and
targets those who have suffered
emotional pain she marks these
individuals and gives them a choice to
either worship her or face death those
who are not mothe are tortured and
sacrificed
number nine it's Papa little in the
Netflix movie no one gets out alive an
ancient entity it's Bubba Lotto is the
central monster antagonist she is
depicted as a gigantic moth-like human
hybrid residing in a stone box that
haunts the protagonists ambar's dreams
she is based on a figure from Aztec
mythology in the movie she is portrayed
as a tall skeleton with a knife pointed
wings and Claws it is suggested that its
bubble has the power to heal the injured
as one character claims that his father
sacrificed many people in exchange for
Good Fortune her abilities are confirmed
in the climax of the movie when the
protagonist suffers a broken foot and
the creature heals that injury in
exchange for sacrifices
number eight pretorius in the 1986 movie
from Beyond which is Loosely based on HP
lovecraft's works here two scientists
use a device called the resonator to
stimulate the pineal gland allowing them
to perceive creatures from another
dimension however the experiment goes
wrong and the head scientist Dr Edward
pretorius is pulled into a parallel
universe by demonic entities he returns
as a grotesque pretorius creature a
shape-shifting master that preys on
others in the laboratory this humanoid
entity has pinkish wet skin photoed feet
and five-fingered hands with a hunched
Back Body a phallic head resembling the
pretorius's face
number seven Behemoth in the movie The
Miz which is a film set in the town of
Bridgeton in Maine here residents
experience a power outage caused by a
strange natural phenomenon as they
gather at a local supermarket the
mysterious Mis engulfs the area
releasing a horde of monstrous creatures
the most prominent one and the most
massive creature in the film is known as
the Behemoth this creature resembles an
arthropod with six multi-jointed legs
and sauropod-like feet its head is
reminiscent of a vertebrate resembling
that of an anglerfish with underbites
and small eyes the Behemoth also has
numerous octopus-like tentacles
protruding from its back and lower body
and adorned with praying matters like
arms
number six the wendigo seen in the movie
antlers which revolves around the school
teacher and her Sheriff brother in an
isolated town in Oregon they become
involved with one of her students
suspecting that he has personal problems
at home unaware that he Harbors an evil
demon the student experiences withdrawal
like symptoms leading to the emergence
of a monstrous creature with an Ambler
sprotting from its mouth this creature
is revealed to be the wendigo rooted in
Native American folklore the wendigo is
a dark spirit that possesses a man
transforming him into a feral Elkhorn
creature that creates human flesh the
more it feeds the hunger it becomes yet
also weaker at the same time
number five the thing seen in the movie
of the same name which is the thing from
1982 which revolves around a group of
American Research scientists in
Antarctica which are disturbed by a
shape-shifting extraterrestrial organism
the creature known as the thing can
assimilate other life forms and take on
their appearance its original physical
characteristics and motivations are
unknown as it has assimilated numerous
species before reaching Earth the thing
lacks a fixed anatomy and its
intelligence varies based on its size
the bigger it is the more intelligent it
is the smaller it is the Dumber it is as
a parasitic life form it seeks to absorb
and assimilate all nearby life form this
enables the parasite to gain shelter and
be able to adapt to any environment that
sustains multicellular life which is its
principal food as you would know and
also since it is a parasite it would
need a hose
number four the oak Drew Jihad also
known as the seven gods of chaos seen in
the movie Hellboy the oak Drew Jihad are
depicted as the ultimate adversaries
although they are only briefly mentioned
by name and scene in a few parts these
beings possess an eerie resemblance to
cephalopods and draw inspiration from
Lovecraft and monsters and themes they
are believed to be enclosed within
crystalline shells situated somewhere in
the vast expanse of outer space they
were released for a short period of time
and boy oh boy they were Beyond gigantic
in size these monsters are the flavor of
cosmic horror being so incomprehensible
in scale and power that humanity is just
a speck of dust in their eyes them being
indifferent to our existence
number three The Marauder seen in a
recent movie called Evil Dead rise The
Marauder is a horfic entity that is seen
at the later parts of the film so evil
dead rise centers around a family and an
aunt that comes to visit one of the
family members a young boy discovers the
Necronomicon after an earthquake and
then later tampers with it leading to
spirits of the deadites the Demonic
creatures to possess his mother than his
sister and him eventually and many other
people living in their building The
Marauder is an entire family unit
Blended together to form a monstrous and
murderous bees which further consumes
and adds other dead people into its
bulging Mass this monster is an
Abomination and indeed a near perfect
Eldritch entity
number two Cthulhu of course we have the
great old one in the 2020 movie
underwater which is a story primarily
focusing on a group of researchers who
find themselves trapped underwater in a
deep sea oil rig following a
catastrophic event they must fight for
survival against unknown creatures and
escape the underwater facility they are
in The Benchmark of cosmic horror and
Eldritch monsters Cthulhu makes an
appearance but not as the cosmic great
old one merely as a gigantic underworld
creature who although is sentin
possesses the Lafayette powers and
commands a host of swarming deep ones he
still falls short on the madness and the
horror fronts yet his design here is
similar to what he has thought to look
like a creature with a humanoid upper
body with long arms above his head and a
mouth full of tentacles
and number one the Xenomorphs so
Xenomorphs are extraterrestrial species
that originate from the alien franchise
introduced in the 1979 film Alien while
the Xenomorphs themselves are not
originally meant for Cosmic horror their
depiction in the franchise does possess
strong elements of it this Cosmic horror
is a sub-genre of horror that emphasizes
the insignificance of humanity in the
face of vast unknowable Cosmic entities
of forces the Xenomorphs embody a sense
of cosmic Horror in several ways first
their Origins are mysterious and tied to
a larger Cosmic cycle they are the
result of a parasitic life cycle they
are seemingly Unstoppable and their life
cycle suggests a purpose Beyond mere
survival their deadly designs and
Affinity towards Darkness also pushes
them to be the best in this case
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam